good you're banning trump okay you
brought this up a couple days ago
where uh reported tuesdays on a slide uh
shown at a goodyear diversity training
that listed black lives matter lesbian
gay bisexual transgender pride under
acceptable
while branding blue lives matter all
lives matter mega attire and politically
affiliated slogans or material under
unacceptable so you can wear black lives
matter
you can wear lgbq
uh community shirts but you cannot wear
blue lives matter you cannot wear all
lives matter you cannot wear mega attire
good goodyear stock declined by the
following uh by following the
president's message which was
broadcasted towards 85 million twitter
followers closing down 2.36 so the
question becomes this
nike comes out and supports
cap
the market
gets excited stock goes to the roof but
goodyear comes out with this position
and they lose 2.36 percent what is the
difference between goodyear and nike
i'll tell you
tell us people
that go to work
have to have tires
because they have cars
okay
good year is typically your nascar
goodyear is typically you know like like
like nike obviously
is built on
a
young
hip type stuff like goodyear is built on
people that put tires on their car
this pissed off so many people that i
there's literally
videos going viral of tire shops taking
the goodyear tires and the goodyear
brand out of their tire shop and the
manager saying we don't sell good years
here anymore why because the guys in the
tire industry typically labor
hardworking
good dudes yeah like they said ah no and
and and dude like
when you have trump saying oh screw you
guys then and the commander in chief is
tweeting out against you uh not so good
for your brand i think that whoever came
up with that stupid slide should
definitely be fired because they just
cost goodyear a crap ton of money
it's unfortunate that you know certain
things are deemed acceptable but then
other sides of the aisle are deemed
unacceptable i mean that's the problem
with the very very and i'm saying i'm
not saying that goodwill uh goodyear is
the liberal liberal left but maybe to
some decision makings are but that's the
problem is that you know free speech
should be free speech if you want to
support mega go ahead support mega you
want to support blm go ahead and support
blm you should not say you can do this
but you can't do this that's free speech
first amendment i mean let's just
receive so you're against what good
you're i'm accepting i'm i'm exact i'm
i'm against anyone saying you can't do
this but you can do this hold on that's
not right i actually disagree
okay
they are
a business
they have every right to tell
their people what you can and can't wear
especially if you're working there okay
you have every single right to do that
the beauty the beautiful thing about the
free market is that we have a right to
decide if we buy your tires or not if we
boycott your your stupid brand so i
think i'm i'm one of the few people that
think they actually have a right to make
whatever rules and restrictions that
they want to because they're a company
and it's america and you've got the
right to dictate what happens in your
bubble but we also have a right not to
buy your stupid product so i'll give you
an idea so i'm in dc and i'm giving a
talk okay there's about 500 people in
the audience and i'm in the dmv area dc
i think it's maryland virginia the whole
uh uh a triangle there and i'm giving a
talk there's about 500 people there it's
myself matt zappala ricky aguilar and a
few other people that are with me
rodolfo and and the hosts
locally were the hearts and corpsmans
christian vesina and billing kimberly
christopher cena hart bill and kimberly
corman it's about 500 people there in
the audience
80 the audience are african-american
okay now when i say african-americans
some are african some are asian some are
african-american some are black so but
is non-white and non-latino okay black
black
and when i'm done with the speech
bill gets up and he has a couple gifts
for me
and he gives me a jacket
by an air force because he's a former
air force veteran he gives me a nice
fancy jacket great
fine
and then he gives me a limited edition
45 make america great again hat in front
of the entire audience
so he gives me the hat
and i'm standing up there black guy he's
a white guy white guy full-on white guy
freaking white so he gets
he trusts him he gives me this
and i'm looking at him i'm saying
huh okay
all right i just got the biggest smile
on my face
and i take it and i have to say
something because
most of the guests weren't his guests
he had he had some guests but it wasn't
the 500 that were his guests so i had to
say i just want you know we support
every decision this just so happens he's
a supporter and he's given this gift and
we appreciate the gift and the gesture
and we got off and some people got upset
and walked out etc etc what's the point
there here's the point
um
when do you think will be the next time
an nba player will be able to go to a
game wearing a mega hat
an nba player an nba player will be able
to go out there while everybody's
standing kneeling with a blm shirt on
one nba player has got a mega hat on
i mean not in trump's america i'll tell
you that but i'm asking you now forget
about trump's america how do you think
the league will react if a play if if a
laker player wears a mega hat
how soon before the lakers trading
because of lebron james how soon
oh that minute that meant you're saying
that okay yeah see to me
that's a league
there's companies there's leagues
companies are what hey you don't want to
wear this totally get it i don't have to
buy the goodyear tire i get it hey nike
you want to do this no problem i'm not
going to buy the shoes or hey more
people are going to buy the shoes good
call on nike worked out for them pepsi
did a commercial years ago didn't work
out for them couple things they did i
don't know if you remember the pepsi
commercial kind of back part on pepsi
terrible commercial that they had right
but the point i'm trying to make to you
right now is
you know there's a big double standard
thing going on right now big double
standard and some are bigger than others
obviously in the nba you and i won't see
anybody wearing a mega hat
it's very
uncomfortable for me to read this and
then goodyear comes out saying issuing a
message the next day that the image
created misconceptions about the company
and its policy stating that the visual
was not created or distributed by
goodyear corporate nor was a part of a
diversity training class so now you
change your position you got to be very
careful nowadays i mean you got to pay
attention to your audience my audience
in the insurance company i run with 16
000 agents here's here's who i have i'm
giving a talk
and i always know who my audience is
last year we have president bush there
we have co late kobe bryant there all
these other guys there we're at the
mirage i'm supposed to be at mgm grand
arena next week and we're doing our
first virtual convention which had a
30-minute conversation with trey gowdy
yesterday what an incredible
conversation yesterday trey gowdy and i
had i had a
45-minute conversation with general
mattis earlier this week and then with
armando's camp pitbulls camp we're
excited to put on a ridiculous event
next week we put a lot of money into
this thing here
i'm giving a talk from stage and i say
how many guys here love aoc and you'll
hear
oh
yeah
like okay we have aoc people here how
many i love obama
whoa
how many love trump whoa
how many guys love bush oh
how many guys have clinton oh
how many guys are christians oh how many
guys are 70 how many guys are this how
many guys are that
and i said how many guys are muslims how
many guys are there there's a place for
you here
i don't care what you are
there's a place for you here
you can build in the company and be
whatever you want but i said here's what
i believe in
i believe in dot dot dot
i believe in capitalism i believe in
free enterprise i believe in freedom of
assembly i believe in freedom of press i
believe in competition these are my
views and here's why and i respect your
views but this is what the company was
founded on you know what happens with us
in the company we're figuring out a way
to get along and this thing keeps
getting bigger and bigger and bigger
when you do things like this what if i'm
your best salesman for goodyear and i'm
a mega person
so what because on the bigger picture if
you really think about it do you
remember when obama was getting elected
everybody thought america was going to
be communistic what happened we're okay
yeah do you remember when bush was
getting reelected second time people
were about to commit suicide because
they thought he was gonna
we're okay you know you remember when
bill clinton and monica lewinsky came
out everybody said oh my gosh guys we're
doing okay the constitution the
declaration of independence what we've
written on those papers are powerful so
goodyear's got to be thinking long term
saying these things could turn around
very quickly you got to understand that
the position has got to be open to allow
people to be there as well so we'll see
what's going to happen a good year i
just don't i'm not excited about the
decision that they made and what they're
doing and we'll see how
customers are going to react
[Music]